[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
baffes un numéro spécial puisqu'il sera
entièrement consacrée aux la question du
vieillissement et de ses enjeux
vous citez deux données intéressantes et
à peu près aujourd'hui vingt mille 25000
samper en france ils seront 300 milles
en 2050 et deuxièment donné la seule
génération dont la population va
augmenter dans les années qui viennent
et celle des plus de 60 ans alors on
voit bien à travers ces deux données
assez symbolique combien notre société
est en train de changer
et quel problème ce changement va poser
sur le plan social sur le plan sociétal
jean-claude économique sur le plan de la
santé
et voilà pourquoi il faut d'ores et déjà
essayé de penser c'est ces changements
c'est ce que nous allons faire
aujourd'hui avec nos invités marie
hélène aubert bonjour je vous êtes la
maire de jouy en josas et vous êtes la
vice présidente du conseil départemental
en charge de l'autonomie anne boucharlat
bonjour vous êtes la fondatrice d'une
association qui s'appelle des grands
s'amusent alors cette la transmission
puisque vous demander à des personnes
âgées malades ou transmettre leur savoir
leur vie leur expérience et vous fait
d'ailleurs une émission de radio
là tu sur radio aligre qui a lieu toutes
les semaines exactement
bonjour bonjour alors vous avez
longtemps présidé saint quentin en
yvelines et vous avez beaucoup agi sur
l'autonomie des handicapés des personnes
âgées pour le maintien à domicile
notamment des personnes âgées et vous
présente deux présidents du pm c'est à
dire le gérant géré handicap à 700 tout
à fait et puis alors avec nous en visio
domedic boulbès bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le président du groupe indépendance
royale qui est un
grand acteur de l'équipement de domicile
des personnes âgées vous atteindre des
spécialistes de ce qu'on appelle la
silver economy on en parlera dans
l'émission et vous venez de publier dans
cette fameuse collection des nuls
le vieillissement et ses enjeux divo
voilà qui va qui va inspirer beaucoup
cette émission et puis avec nous
également
romain gano bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
responsable
autonomie et services chez ag2r la
mondiale ce qui fait très plaisir à
robert cadalbert d'un soir oui parce que
ça me parait remercié jeudi le mondial
de financer l'aide aux aidants au
travers de cette action n'a donc que
l'on fait donc c'est pas c'est un acteur
important de ce domaine alors peut-être
pour commencer ce qui serait intéressant
c'est de de dresser une sorte d'état des
gi joe the sith est de donner tout à
l'heure l'état des lieux on pourra
peut-être plus à même l'état des vieux
[Musique]
dominic gould baisse dans votre livre
vous citer un certain nombre de données
qui so qui sont pas ce que j'attends
d'eux millions de centenaires dans le
monde dans 25 ans tous trois millions
deux bas mot dix ans dans les dents deux
en 2050
en france je le disais c'est le pays qui
compte déjà le plus de centenaires avec
21000 centenaire y aura à peu près 300
millions en 2050
quelles sont les données vous qui vous
impressionne le plus dans ces dans cet
état des lieux justement alors il ya
deux phénomènes intéressant la première
c'est la faulx prendre la mesure de
l'évolution en 1900 on avait en france
sans centenaire well as pas plus
aujourd'hui effectivement va me laissa
va être multiplié par 15 à peu près dans
les 20 années qui arrivent deuxièmes
chiffre intéressant c'est qu'un bébé sur
deux bébés sur trois qui naissent
aujourd'hui en tout cas les petites
filles hop à 60 ans c'est à dire que
vous avez 60% à 65% des
des petites filles qui naissent et 55%
des petits garçons qui naissent
aujourd'hui pendant qu'on parle qui
vivront plus longtemps
oui donc ça c'est des données canton d
aider des responsables politiques par
exemple c'est évident et vous appelez de
l'autonomie au conseil départemental
c'est évidemment des données qui sont
qui tient caterpillar et qui changent
eux qui doivent changer notre regard sur
la société
ça oblige à réfléchir à des politiques
adaptées c'est sur ce qu'on dit que
l'europe vieillit que le monde vieillit
surtout l'asie d'ailleurs mais dans les
yvelines aussi et dans les yvelines plus
qu'ailleurs d'ailleurs plus que dans les
autres départements d'île de france
les + 2 on vieillit on va vieillir plus
blond tous les vides longtemps c'est
sérieux les projections puisque tout le
monde est arrivé en même temps sur la
ligne rennes ou presque avec des enfants
et maintenant on a les courbes qui
montrent que dans les années qui
viennent la probable le problème de
vieillissement est un gros problème pour
50 en libye alors avec dominic gould
buzz c'est une sorte d'inégalité qui
existe toujours c'est plutôt les
pharmaciens sur 100 sont sur 10 ans
teneur il ya 9 femmes je crois sur dix
personnes un homme quoi oui vous avez à
peu près 85 90 % puis si on fait ce
qu'on appelle les super centenaires
alors les super centenaires ce sont nos
concitoyens qui ont passé 110 ans et là
il y en avait je crois 300 en france en
début d'année dont cinq hommes
donc vous voyez effectivement d'ailleurs
les scientifiques expliquent assez mal
mais globalement les femmes disent plus
vieille s'inquiète d'explication
vraiment mis sur la table pour l'instant
probablement une inégalité de biologique
enfin il ya beaucoup de facteurs qui
peuvent expliquer ça et est-ce que je
continue à cet état un peu d'aidé des
lieux est-ce que grandissante en est
cette armée dans quel état parce que
c'est ça le problème de vieillissement
c'est pas seulement l'âge c'est aussi
dans quel état on est donc l état santé
on est oui c'est si vous voulez
aujourd'hui il ya une espèce de
je trouve souvent une confusion des
genres entre le sujet du vieillissement
et le sujet de la dépendance
on assimile assez souvent âge avancé
avec dépendances mais c'est faux vous
avez aujourd'hui passé soixante dix huit
pour cent des gens qui sont dépendants
au sens désir que madame du conseil
général connaît parfaitement qui est un
indice de dépendants gir de 1,6 et on
est dépendant on est gir 1 2 3 ou 4 et
aujourd'hui ça n'est que excusez moi du
mot mais ça n'est que 8 % des gens qui
sont dépendantes donc 92 % des seniors
après 70 ans sont autonomes
même si parfois ils peuvent avoir des
difficultés à exécuter certains actes de
la vie quotidienne nonobstant il reste
autonome donc c'est quand même important
de souligner que pour l'essentiel les
seniors sont autonomes donc ça ça pose
enfin ça veut dire de beaucoup de choses
des axes y sont autonomes et robert
cadalbert vous avez beaucoup travaillé
là dessus on peut on se dit qu'au fond
on pourrait les maintenir à domicile le
plus longtemps possible
c'est un voeu tout le monde sait et
rythmant à domicile que les gens
vieillissent mieux
plus on vieillit on a on a nos routines
et on ne peut pas être changé de cire
outin
après ce qui est important c'est de
donner les moyens de rester à domicile
soit par le logement soit ce qu'on fait
par exemple au maire en terre dans les
moyens services d'infirmières à domicile
des deux soignantes des accueils de jour
on veut monter un centre de répit serre
que quand on est à domicile c'est vrai
quand on a un malade par une belle mère
handicapée souffler simplement il
respirait et bien les accueils de jour
sont quelque chose de très important
pour permettre ce maintien à domicile à
peu près possible
romain gayot justement quelles sont les
actions qu'on peut mener pour rebelles
ce qu'on pourrait appeler le bien
vieillir question très largement c'est
une vraie une vraie problématique
aujourd'hui de coordination des acteurs
et surtout une problématique de faire
que de non accès au droit
aujourd'hui ce qui est une des limites
aujourd'hui pour le bien de dire si tu
les personnes ne connaissent pas les
droits
lequel on est les dispositifs qui
pourraient les aider pour moi la
première action est une action
d'information massive sur ce qui existe
en termes d'adaptation du logement de
maintien à domicile
des doses aidants ou de soutien des plus
fragiles on a la chance aujourd'hui en
france d'avoir une écosystèmes du bien
vieillir qui est très riche qui propose
de nombreuses solutions d'avoir des
financements du maintien à domicile sont
parmi les plus les plus fortes d'europe
donc il ya bien une question de
coordination et d'accès aux droits
traités justement mairie les nobel sur
ce financement enfin arrivée vous devez
avoir des demandes là dessus quand
comment ça se passe là bas il ya un très
bon retient pour favoriser le maintien à
domicile dont chacun reconnaît que c'est
évidemment la meilleure solution
donc elle est possible la meilleure
solution et puis le souhait des
personnes de le souhait aujourd'hui il
ya seulement 3 % des personnes qui
souhaitent vieillir en ehpad donc
vraiment là l'idée c'est vraiment
d'accompagner ce souhait des personnes
âgées enfin qu'ils vieillissent de
qu'elle puisse rester à domicile le plus
longtemps possible et face à cet enjeu
démographique qui nous attend c'est de
d'inverser la règle là où la règle est
aujourd'hui de vieillir en ehpad
on inverse la règle et on va miser
massivement sur le maintien domicile en
créant une agence de l'autonomie
d'ailleurs pour encourager et développer
cet écosystème du maintien à domicile
les services d'aidé à domicile etc
c'est quoi la joueuse de l'autonomie
c'est un gip qui vient d'être créé à la
fin la fin de l'année dernière fin 2020
pour pouvoir justement développer tous
les services qui accompagnent le
maintien à domicile y compris le
numérique je pense qu'on y reviendra un
petit peu plus loin avec dominique
boulbès mais le numérique va jouer un
rôle important dans le maintien à
domicile
je peux confirmer l'information quelque
chose d'essentiel sur ce jeu par
remercier une nouvelle fois j'étais à la
mondiale complète mais m c'est important
parce que les droits puisque c'est ça la
question
les droits les gens ne connaissent pas
on a mis en place aussi une sorte
d'appartement témoins pour aménagement
l'aménagement pour les gens qui sont en
perte d'autonomie
il ya des petites choses la fourchette
le bol et la home errants terre
l'agglomération a mis en place un
showroom peut dire jaune de matériel
pour aider les gens à vivre à leur
domicile
donc c'est toutes ces petites choses mis
bout-à-bout qui permet effectivement de
remplir se veut tout le monde de rester
le plus longtemps à 2 1 à domicile et
dans de bonnes conditions et dans
vraiment dominique lebel justement vous
êtes le président jay z d'indépendance
royal qui je tourne lutte en finlande où
se se bat en tout cas pour faciliter le
maintien à domicile des personnes âgées
dans les dents les découvertes ou dans
les trouvailles sont les des outils vous
mettez à leur disposition quels sont
ceux qui vous au lait les plus marquées
alors si vous voulez avant de répondre
je pense que je voudrais rebondir sur le
ce que disait monsieur il ya cinq
minutes qui concerne l interaction
sociale que nous ce qu'on voit si vous
voulez c'est que au delà d approche
segmentée et techniques financement etc
etc
nous on fait à peu près car ce point me
l'entretien parents de deux heures avant
on est vraiment au plus près du terrain
est ce qu'on voit c'est que le la
condition essentielle du bien vieillir
c'est le fait que la personne puisse
être maintenu dans ses différents
cercles de sociabilité le cercle amical
le sac familiale le serbe de voisinage
le sac associatif et quatre sacs et des
sociologues définissent un état de mort
sociale quand vous avez des personnes
qui n'appartiennent aucun de ces quatre
cirque et moi j'ai par exemple à titre
personnel passé deux ans de ma vie dans
une chambre d'hôpital
suite à un accident de vie et on devient
fou quand on est seul on devient fou on
de la kommandantur donc ça veut dire que
le maintien d'interactions sociales
c'est ça permet d'éviter une espèce de
leur campement d'une spirale négative
qui est une espèce de rebond entre les
déficiences fonctionner les défis sans
ceux ci géologique si vous voulez c'est
à dire que vous avez des gens qui ne
rencontrent plus de personnes donc qui
ont des capacités physiques qui diminue
parce qu'elles n'ont plus d'interactions
sociales et donc l indien qui a pas été
beaucoup étudié jusqu'à présent entre le
fait de maintenir des relations avec
autrui
le fait de parler simplement d'aller
voir des gens et l'état physique et les
médecins les gériatres le savent bien
sans que ça soit
encore une fois un phénomène qui était
étudié précisément que ça devient que
y'a rebonds si vous voulez entre le
maintien de l'interaction sociale le
maintien de la relation avec autrui et
le maintien de l'indépendance
fonctionnel au sens physique du terme
c'est extrêmement important parce que
c'est ça je pense qu'ils de gouverner
nos politiques publiques beaucoup plus
qu'ils approchent finalement très
segmenté et techniciste un mois je mets
vraiment pour une approche ce que fait
ag2r par exemple je mise beaucoup pour
une approche holistique des problèmes
une approche une approche globale des
problèmes si vous voulez alors hier d'en
vendre et donc alors après si vous
voulez dans les dents les si on revient
maintenant en faire un focus sur les
aspects techniques
qu'est-ce que vous avez vous avez des
zones qui sont dangereuses vous avez par
exemple la salle de bains et action
logement a lancé il ya un an et demi
sans de s'achever un programme
d'investissement volonté où ils ont aidé
à équiper 100 mille seniors qui ont
remplacé des baignoires à des douches
ça paraît tout bête c'est pas forcément
très sexy qu'on en parle comme ça mais
c'est vite il une baignoire 65 cm de
haut on peut vite tomber quand on non
jambes la baignoire pour sortir ou
rentrer on peut glisser et donc le fait
de remplacer une baignoire par un 12 bat
ma foi c'est ça peut être un élément clé
ya des éléments par exemple qui sont
très connus dans les pays de culture
anglo saxonne l'angleterre les europe du
nord la hollande tous et le canada les
usa comme les monte escalier - sky est
chez nous c'est encore un peu
stigmatisant mais vous avez des pays
comme l'angleterre où c'est devenu aussi
banal d'installer à monte-escalier que
d'installer je sais pas patrice qu'est
ce qu'on pourrait dire un des volets
roulants chez vous par exemple
vous en avez 12 fois plus qu'ils sont
installés en haut mais douze fois pas de
ce prochain 12 fois plus qu'il soit
installé en angleterre à population
comparable ou en lan et c'est qu'en
france
donc si vous voulez le réflexe équipes
moe domicile est en train de naître et
une vraie prise de conscience que
vieillir c'est à la fois que l'appel à
des services à la personne ça c'est bien
dans le paysage mental des gens on sait
ce que c'est depuis et loire bourlout de
95 mais également d'équiper son domicile
comment croire à tout à l'heure
peut-être notamment avec des solutions
numériques
je reviendrai ce que vous disiez sur le
lien social qui est totalement
indispensable on a vu et dès hier avec
la crise de l'aco vite dans les ehpad
combien ça ça fait de dépression
peut-être peut-être que ça tu es aussi
une certaine forme de deux personnes en
dehors de la maladie elle-même
c'est vrai que ça coco justement à
nouveau char là avec votre association
des grands s'amusent
vous créez vous aussi dû dire social 6
et vous allez vous allez demander en
demandant à ces personnes âgées à ses
aînés de témoigner c'est aussi les faire
rencontrer d'autres personnes d'autres
générations
c'est à moi quand j'ai créé mon
association sur qui s'appelle les grands
s'amusent sur la transmission de nos
aînés l'idée c'est de c'est vraiment de
d'être dans la transmission de d'être
dans le lien social intergénérationnel
en afrique on dit quand tu as une
personne âgée meurt une bibliothèque
brûle et c'est vrai que les personnes
âgées se sont ce sont nos mémoires en
mémoire vive
ils ont énormément d'expérience plus
plus on avance en âge plus forcément on
a on a l'expérience des choses à
raconter
on a eu des vies riche on a eu on a
plein de choses et donc je vois là j'ai
choisi de
de partir de là dessus et de fer et
puisse aller ça les met en valeur aussi
de les faire parler d'eux depuis
et puis je m'aperçois que les jeunes
sont très curieux de sauver le plus âgé
dans mon association les jeunes par
exemple c'est une jeune qui m'a dit
l'autre jour
moi j'ai plein j'aurais aimé poser plein
de questions à ma grand mère sur
l'éducation sur l'amour mais dans ma
famille on parle pas trop pour x raisons
donc je suis ravi de pouvoir poser ces
questions dans vos ateliers et puis dans
mon émission de radio aussi parce que
j'invite à une personne âgée et un jeune
est un jeune qui va opposer dès qu'il ya
vraiment un blog un échange l'idée c'est
de se rapprocher les uns des autres
c'est vraiment créer des synergies comme
ça et on s'aperçoit que contrairement à
ce qu'on dit je trouve que les jeunes
sont très demandés très demandée on est
très curieux et puis et puis j'ai à un
agriculteur aussi à la retraite qui m'a
qui m'a dit moi je vais en fait je vais
faire un come à des changes je vais être
logés dans une famille de jeunes
agriculteurs et en échange je vais
apporter mon expérience
donc c'est super intéressant il ya plein
de choses comme ça il ya plein de
synergies et je pense que de temps en
temps on n'ose pas ou alors une personne
un peu âgées perd confiance n'ose pas et
on peut le impulser des choses comme ça
et mon association mon émission c'est
impulser des choses voilà donner envie
donner de dire c'est possible possible
s'il ya des instants et on voit qu'en
fait le monde à ces demandeurs d'exact
exactement moi je trouve que les gens
sont sont plus curieux qu'on le qu'on le
dit et donc donc voilà ça fait des
échanges qui sont très riches
l'autre jour mon invité les invités mon
émission jeudi dernier c'était un
ethnologue qui en résulte est un
producteur et qui racontait que l'huile
a démarré avec les premières caméras
avant c'était du super 8 et que ça lui a
donné une liberté de mouvement dont dans
ce travail et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
les jolies cesson l'impression que tout
est fait pas que c'est fait
et puis en fait quand on leur raconte ça
c'est génial parce qu'ils ont fait c'est
des gens qui ont exploré donc c'est
possible
il ya toujours des choses à explorer
donc ça donne aussi je pense ça peut
susciter des vocations ça donne le goût
de la curiosité c'est donc c'est plein
d'exemples comme ça qu'ils sont qui sont
super intéressant fin moi en tout cas ça
me nourrit déjà il ya une chose
d'ailleurs très intéressante dans votre
livre 2010 google buzz c'est au fond
l'image qu'on peut avoir de la
vieillesse est l'image que donne le la
sociologie de tammo c'est une image
assez péjorative au fond on considère
souvent la vieillesse comme ce passage
obligé parce qu'on peut pas faire
autrement
vers la mort or c'est quand même tout à
fait autre chose la vie et le
vieillissement et la vieillesse
moi je crois que si vous voulez madame
faisait allusion tout à l'heure aux
sociétés africaines par exemple que je
peux je connais bien si vous voulez il
ya une espèce de contradiction
fondamentale entre nos sociétés modernes
mais là je parle beaucoup des pays
développés les pays occidentalisés au
sens on va dire économique du terme et
culturel du terme aussi d'ailleurs
est ce le fait de vieillir on vit
aujourd'hui dans des sociétés qui sont
tout entière tournée vers l'avenir vers
le futur demain doit être mieux
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas tout le temps
vécu comme ça vous êtes dans beaucoup de
sociétés et on dit dans le présent et
demain on n'a pas forcément besoin de
changer beaucoup de choses alors
qu'aujourd'hui dans nos sociétés prenez
l'histoire de là par exemple vous prenez
la et ben jeune artiste d'art
contemporain il est forcément bien parce
qu'il est innovant on oublie l'émotion
on oublie le message induit beaucoup de
choses mais bientôt fait que ça soit
différent qu'on n'ait jamais fait est en
soi une valeur positive et donc les
personnages et dans ce schéma cette
façon d'être si vous voulez pas comment
dire de nos sociétés modernes qui avons
une réflexion théologique les personnes
âgées c'est un peu en contradiction avec
ce que sont nos sociétés dès qu on est
tourné vers le projet vers le futur que
dans un entreprise par exemple pourront
essayer de faire de la science pour
faire de la croissance est simple même
pas très bien d'enfin savoir pourquoi on
se pose plus ces questions ont postulé
question de la raison d'être des choses
pas une personne âgée sekkaki est moins
dans le futur on dit ce qu'on peut dire
ce qu'on veut
moi j'ai 56 ans je pas encore tout à
fait dans les seniors oui pour les gens
du marketing je suis quand même moins
dans le futur que a 20 ans quand on
pense à son premier boulot à cette étude
et c'est donc une espèce de
contradiction et donc comme disait
madame elle parlé de la relation entre
les grands parents les petits enfants
c'est une relation qui a ceci de
différent avec celle qu'on avec les
parents c'est que la relation qu'on a
avec ses parents elle les données tandis
que celle qu'on a avec les grands
parents est à construire et donc un
espace de construction il ya un espace
d'intelligence sociale une espèce n'est
ce pas ce qui laisse la place à
l'épaisseur humaine à une espèce de
tissu de relations un peu différent qui
fait qu'effectivement de trouver des
points on peut tisser des liens entre ce
que sont nos sociétés encore une fois
qu'ils sont une espèce de mécanique
implacable comme ça qu'ils qui croient
qu'ils croient qu'ils croient qu'ils qui
détruit l'environnement avec des anciens
qui sont des formes de migrants culturel
finalement qui vient de notre temps
voilà est qui qui ont des choses à nous
apprendre
robert cadalbert j'étais bien géré une
fois j'ai même parlé de ça avec giscard
d'estaing qu'il disait au fond on
utilise assez mal les anciens présidents
de la république bal de leur expérience
est-ce que vous par exemple des
politiques elle vous voir pour vous
demander des conseils
est ce que j'y vienne pas me voir je
vais voir si c est ce qu on utilise bien
au fond l'expérience certainement passé
on parlait de l'afrique l'été puisque
saint quentin en yvelines ont été
jumelés avec mopti au mali
la première chose c'est vu dans dans le
domaine le conseil des anciens
c'est vrai que le rôle des anciens est
pas tout à fait vrai qu'il faut être
dans le présent c'est vrai qu'il faut
avoir des projets à haute tension peut
pas venir si on n'a pas de projets quel
que soit son âge
monsieur avait 56 l'ombre je peux me
dire j'en ai vingt ans de plus donc je
peux et de vacciner b
vous aimeriez être centenaire non le
losc
si vous faites des régionaux le
vieillissement est indispensable si on
veut vivre de mon temps ça c'est
indéniable non je pense que c'est il
faut faire des projets il faut survivre
vivent dans le vivre c'est avoir des
projets pendant 20 ans au niveau de
l'agglomération c'était tous les jours
j'étais submergé de projets maintenant
je vis avec des projets donc ça soit
celui de giroud handicap ou mayrand
taillé un beau projet que soit le projet
de l'institut de santé par le sport
parra sport connectés qui va se mettre à
saint quentin et mines à l'état de
projet et il faut avoir des projets dans
les rangées rejoint que j'allais avoir
des projets mais en vivant pleinement le
présent c'est indispensable de
d'apprécier par exemple ce qu'on vit sur
le plateau cet instant présent c'est
quelque chose de fondamental mais je
pense que plus on vieillit plus on a
cette chance de penser au présent
d'abord parce que on sait que les jours
plus ça passe moi y en a donc il faut il
vient justement balle mais on est on est
plus ou moins égaux devrait être bien
que ces dames sont un peu plus
privilégiés que les hommes mais il faut
absolument vivre au présent mais tout en
ayant des projets c'est indispensable
donc pour répondre à votre question bien
sûr le choix une demande soit je veux
voir les nouveaux présidents et ça se
passe très bien c'est stand by les
nouvelles stars dont j'aurais aimé
intervenir sur le sujet je pense qu
intéressant dans ce qu'il vient de dire
pardon me dominique toujours la question
de la place aujourd'hui du retraité dans
les politiques publiques qui leur sont
destinés aujourd'hui on voit le retraité
souvent perçu comme l'objet de la
politique où on va être ou attaches a
exprimé le besoin qu'ont les retraités
vont présenter des solutions
aujourd'hui les retraités ont des envies
et les envies c'est différent d'un
besoin l'envi c'est ce qui permet
aujourd'hui de ce projet ou dans
l'avenir ou dans le moment présent et
aujourd'hui pour moi la place du
retraité
elle est fondamentale dans les
politiques du bis du doigt co-créé
participer à l'évaluation des produits
des solutions qui lui sont destinés
sinon on va arriver
sur quelque chose qu'on connaît bien
dominique ou plusieurs sons du son sont
à côté du besoin des envies des seniors
le crif où il faut pas voir le retraité
comme comme une personne dépendante ou
comme un objet de soin ou qu'on a un
objet public mais comme une personne qui
doit exprimer son envie ses envies et
dans ses envies la première ya vieillir
chez lee le deuxième sujet sur lequel je
voulais réagir et et les solidarités
intergénérationnelles on a parlé d'
intergénérationnel tout à l'heure et
rappeler juste deux chiffres les
retraités aujourd'hui sur saône étude
insee de 2018 contribuer à hauteur de 3
milliards d'euros pour les dépenses de
leurs petits-enfants et trois milliards
d'euros supplémentaires pour les
dépenses de leurs enfants on n'a pas
encore les chiffres sur 2020 mais on
sait plus que ces chiffres ont très
largement augmenter car les retraités
ont été solidaires de leurs de leurs
descendants
pendant la crise financière et la crise
qu'ovide une deuxième donné qu'il faut
savoir aujourd'hui c'est que il ya eu un
énorme mouvement de solidarité des
jeunes vers les retraités pendant le
premier confinement de jeunes qui ont
souhaité s'engager dans des missions
bénévoles ils ont tellement été nombreux
que les associations n'avaient pas assez
de mission à pouvoir pour soutenir les
retraités donc on évoquera tout à
l'heure le sujet du risque de choc des
générations mais moi je vais intervenir
avant aujourd'hui les faits aujourd'hui
tendent à conclure à une solidarité
intergénérationnelle bien plus fort que
le risque à venir de choc des
générations on peut le on peut évoquer
tout de suite puisque vous l'avez vous
l'abordez c'est un sondage qui est paru
une enquête qui montre que 56% des
français craignent un conflit entre
seniors et jeunesse à l'occasion de la
crise de lac de la coved
c'est vrai que on a beaucoup dit pardon
que la politique qui a été suivi avec je
sais pas les par exemple les
vaccinations dans les ehpad l'évacuation
des personnes âgées en premier ça
consistait à favoriser les lieux et un
peu à sacrifier les jeunes et c'est pas
totalement faux non plus non qu'il avait
reçu mais on entend on entend beaucoup
je suis content c'est un peu inquiétant
d'ailleurs j'en entends des jeunes qui
disent on est confiné à cause des
personnes âgées et les personnes âgées
qui disent bon on est confiné à cause
donc voilà il va falloir prendre garde à
ça dans les dents les mois qui viennent
je pense pas avoir ce conflit de
générations a ajouté
voyez une chose qui m'a qui m'énerve
c'est la dette la dette
on dépense mais je vois le cas de saint
quentin en yvelines l'agglomération de
saint quentin devine à une dette
importante mais enfin je dis aux jeunes
via mon fils mme oui mais tu as pu aller
au lycée il ya le théâtre il ya le
vélodrome il ya les jeux olympiques il
ya une faculté de médecine il ya même
même une télévision locale
tous à vous toute votre jeunesse vous en
profiter alors forcément on en profite
et à un crédit
mais c'est pas simplement pour les
fédérations pardon a accru la dette que
vous payez sans doute et je ne le veux
pas
l'important c'est pas la tête c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait de cette dette
akouala servi si elle a servi à faire
une télévision locale c'est bien ou pas
bien quand c'est évident quand ces
universités on a créé les versité à 50
animer une fac de métier personne vit
tous les jeunes qui sortent de la fac de
médecine de 50 en ligne et on pas dire
bah oui la dette vous n'auriez pas dû
dépenser d'argent
donc aujourd'hui on parle toujours de
dettes mais on parle pas des actifs
concerne l'entreprise il ya un actif
passif jeu bien qu'il ya une dette un
passif mais l'actif c'est
qu'effectivement les jeunes ont pu aller
à l'université
ils peuvent aller au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines il va avoir
les jeunes à sévère avec un vélodrome
ben oui mais c'est ça qui est important
qu'il faut dire aux jeunes d'ailleurs
ils le vivent bien un de cette façon
parce qu'ils vont à l'université ils
vont au théâtre ils vont au vélodrome
mais ça c'est un coup et c'est normal
qu'on partage cette charge financière
entre générations passées le débat
politique mais c'est vrai qu'au beau
votre peut penser aussi que certains
gouvernements depuis 40 ans endetté la
france et qu'on aurait plus de la nette
impression ça c'est un vrai mais c'est
ça le vrai débat qu'est ce qu'on fait de
l'argent qu'est ce qu'on fait ici ses
dépenses d'investissement en effet ces
débats parfois aussi ses dépenses pour
pour utiliser des gens qui sont
peut-être pas tout à fait nécessaire
mais lui non
dominique boulbès est justement sur ce
conflit de générations vous le craignez
ou pas alors je pense qu'il faut il faut
remonter un tout petit peu d'aller à
moins qu vide et je pense pas que pour
l'instant plus parler de fracture entre
les générations mais au moins d'une mode
une fissure avant que vides ici on se
remet un peu dans une perspective un
tout petit peu plus longue et une espèce
de mouvement qui est apparu qui est né
en australie
le mouvement qui s'appelle ok boomer ok
boomer
c'est une députée australienne qui se
faisait taclé par députés australiens
dans leur hémicycle députés australiens
tu as pokémon âge je crois et l'envoyer
promener de reversement luisant ok
boomer alors ça veut dire quoi ok boomer
c'est ce que monsieur évoqua l'instant
cette espèce de reproches qui peut être
fait par la génération actuelle les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui aux boomers
donc les gens nés entre 45 et 70 60
classement les pays d'avoir créé de la
dette et détruit l'environnement
et si vous voulez il ya quelque chose
qui est intéressant et une vision large
du sujet c'est que vous avez une espèce
d'inversion des valeurs qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est que traditionnellement
on les personnes âgées les anciens
traditionnellement sont ceux qui se
préoccupent de la collectivité qui se
préoccupe des générations qui viennent
du futur au sens plein du terme etc
et puis cette espèce de reproches c'est
tout mouvement great attenberg etc
c'est tout ça c'est assez conséquent
quand même et moi qui ai quatre enfants
j'ai deux ados à la maison on l'entend
c'est une musique qui s'entend vraiment
en disant mais finalement les vieux vous
avez détruit l'environnement effets de
la dette alors c'est intéressant parce
que c'est pas complètement faux il faut
toujours moi monsieur
j'entends ce que vous dites mais je suis
pas d'accord on peut aussi faire des
bonnes choses à voir d'actifs sans
générer d'être les allemands n'ont pas
généré
diddy gaz ex-le mans et discours
parfaitement capable que je sache le
site indications de santé n'est pas plus
mauvais que le nôtre par contre il vaut
mieux gérer ces questions de gestion
c'est pas une question de philosophie et
du coup ce mouvement avec la crise du
coc vie eh bien il s'est finalement je
trouve un peu ces fissures
c'est un peu comme en dise un peu
agrandie s'appeler l'ares j parce que
c'est pas tout à fait faux quand même et
ça il faut aussi entendre ces choses là
parce que bien discuter si longtemps
c'est pas tout à fait faux que de dire
que le coc vite ces mêmes vrai que le
pot vide a touché les plus âgés c'est je
rappelle que l'âge moyen du décès du co
vide quand on pose la question aux gens
on leur demande quelle a joué un de
décès du co vie donc on répond 60 ans
non ces quatre cent vingt quatre ans et
cette moyenne 84 ans et sept mois
c'est ça la joie un ddc du covin et donc
certains jeunes peut avoir l'impression
d'être une génération sacrifiée pour des
gens qui avaient peu de temps à vivre
moi je suis bien sûr contre ceci parce
que la vie humaine ne se mesure pas à
l'aune des moqueries à sa ville vous qui
respire et vive la question n'est pas là
une espèce de valeur sacrée à la vie
humaine qui transcende je dirais un peu
qui sacrifiait par acquis mais
nonobstant ce sont des choses qu'il faut
entendre quand même hein et je pense pas
qu'on puisse pour l'instant parler de
conflit des générations parce que si
vous voulez quand vous regardez sur la
planète
de quelles sont les valeurs qui sont
universellement partagée sur la planète
il ya des valeurs qui ne sont pas le cas
ce que je peux dire vous avez des dames
sur le plateau le droit des femmes c'est
pas du tout une valeur qui est partagé
ces deux valeurs qui est positif dans 5
% de la population mondiale a plus les
valeurs religieuses
il ya autant de religion que de pop
c'était il ya très peu de valeurs
universellement
par contre dans les valeurs partagées
universellement il ya le respect des
anciens à peu près partout et développé
à développer au fonds d'afrique
les yvelines je sais pas où moi j'habite
à mâcon par tout le respect qu'on doit
et la bienveillance comporte à ses
grands parents est quand même assez
universel partager si vous laissez ici
suivant un socle un socle de l'humanité
qui qui se retrouve vraiment partout je
vois qu'ils aient beaucoup voyagé je
connais pas civilisation qui ne des
situations qui n'apportent pas de droits
aux enfants aux familles il y en a pas
c'est même la majorité mais pour les
grands parents non il faudrait pas
justement que laisser cette fissure
s'agrandir parce qu'elle existe et que
ce vraiment à cette petite musique vous
avez détruit la planète
vous avez fait n'importe quoi elle
existe et donc pour finir une espèce
d'inversion des valeurs ce qu'ils
voulaient c'est à dire que c'est
vraiment ça c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
jeunes les adolescents
moi quand j'entends parler mes filles
tous leurs copains etc
ils sont infiniment plus préoccupés de
la du collectif au sens large du terme
et de ce qui va se passer d'un
générations futures kalemie moi je les
tiens à leur époque des années
ça fait quoi ça dans les années 70 soit
ils sont infiniment plus préoccupé par
ça il ya une espèce d'inversion des
valeurs comme ça si vous est donc ce
mouvement ok boomer les débats à
l'occasion du comic cd c'est ce qu'on
appelle en sociologie des ce sont des
signaux faibles
ce sont des signaux faibles qu'il faut
savoir écouter vraiment attentivement je
pense il y avait un économiste qui
disait quand on dit qu'on sauve des vies
c'est pas vrai on fait juste les buts
que les prolonger et on ne prolonge que
celles qui sont déjà au delà de
l'espérance de vie donc s'amuser
c'était un peu provocateur mais c'était
une façon de de risque c'est peut-être
un tableau on n'en parle pas comme on
vient de dire 80 % plus de 80% des
dessins sont des retraités ont fait un
petit calcul tout ça c'est à peu près 1
2 milliard d'économies que le coni
permet de faire c'est la réalité des
chiffres
dire aussi que les lambeaux dire aussi
qu on s'endette aussi beaucoup faire
mais après des inconnus sur les
retraites enfants branchement sur ce
conflit de générations vous le sentez un
peu santé et puis je pense que de toute
façon on fait tous des erreurs donc nos
grands parents nos ailleurs on fait des
erreurs et puis de toute façon c'est à
la jeune génération maintenant de
trouver des solutions pi de north qui
devait reste qu'il est allé offrir des
bons et risque 10 et dominic gould
sekita c'est vrai c'est que cette idée
du monde qu'on va laisser elle est
relativement récente jusqu'à pendant
très longtemps dans l'histoire on a vécu
sur l'instant présent sur comment vivre
comment voilà l'idée de l'idée de
l'avenir de quel monde on va laisser de
quel sera le monde dans qu'elles vivront
les enfants deux petits-enfants elle est
relativement récente probable en plus
présente chez les jeunes que peut-être
il s'organise bien il ya beaucoup de
startups justement ils sont très
sensibilisés à forcément à
l'environnement dont il ya beaucoup de
choses qui se créent et de deux voiles à
2-2 d'initiative
donc je trouve que les jeunes
effectivement peut-être qu'ils ont pas
contents mais mais il reste pas sans
rien faire et ils ont ils font des
actions donc moi j'ai comme j'ai
confiance en eux j'avais dit que voilà
c'est ils vont trouver les solutions
un nouvel équilibre générationnel à
trouver il ya une place face à ce
vieillissement de notre population il ya
une place à redonner à la personne âgée
je pense dans nos sociétés à valoriser
cet appui
cette avancée en âge c'est une chance
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il ya un an
et nous et beaucoup de retraités qui est
mieux au monde à benquet que serait
notre tissu associatif
que serait notre tissu associatif sans
les retraités quand même une question
qui est une question essentielle même si
romain gadaud avait raison de dire je
crois que c'était vous plaisir avec 8%
d'aider des personnes au fond qui sont
dépendantes
c'est quand même la question des ehpad
vous allez lutter un peu contre la
le mode de vie dans certains répondent
non et une évidence fonctionnement des
ehpad appartements et deviennent de plus
en plus privé parce que il faut pas
mettre un ehpad
il ya des ehpad et associatif qui
moquent bien quand on compare ce qui se
passe forcément les ehpad privée jai pas
donné de noms qui ont été émises sur la
scène pendant cette crise devenue comme
id
forcément il faut que les actionnaires
puissent toucher des dividendes
c'est d'ailleurs le placement préféré ou
qui est le plus porteur actuellement sur
des trucs donc il est bien évident que
les responsables des ehpad
il ya il faut qu'il tire ses ressources
sur l'argent alors il ya bien sûr tous
les discours sur leurs pas les
conditions
mais il y en a qui est beaucoup plus
important surtout dans les pattes ils
sont médicalisés est ce que il ya
effectivement une médication avec le
personnel qui va tout le monde connaît
bien que le trouver des aides soignants
des infirmières et tout ça j'ai eu
l'expérience de voir comment un accueil
de jour alzheimer qu'on a par exemple on
me hantait et un lieu d'accueil d d d
alzheimer dans un ehpad ça rien à voir
alors quand on parle au directeur de la
rsr
ben oui ils ont pas le nom de personnel
parce qu'en plus dans le nombre de
personnels il compte le directeur le
cuisinier le concierge et en fin de
compte les soignants qui doit être là
pour s'occuper des mets absolument pas
respectée mais le directeur de la rs il
me dit bah oui qu'est-ce que je vais
faire je vais fermer l'ehpad
qu'est ce que fais je fais en ehpad il
était coincé alors c'est un système
quand même au coach que je trouve tout
le monde trouve son compte sauf le
patient sauf la personne très diverses
si ils ferment l'ehpad le directeur de
rfo qu'ils ouvrent des lits dans les
hôpitaux de gériatrie savez combien ça
coûte un lit de j'ai raté d'un hôpital
c'est beaucoup plus cher et en plus le
patient il paye pas alors on va mieux
ouvrir cette façon là donc le directeur
de la rs1000 bon bah c'est bien qu'il ya
des ehpad soit disant médicalisé qui ne
sont pas moi je me retrouve dans les
comptes de public de l'hôpital
mais d'un autre côté vous avez des
patients qui sont dans des ehpad et qui
sont mal traités de cette façon parce
qu' on respecte pas ce genre de choses
est ce mécanisme en fin de compte c'est
impossible reste de cette façon là le
coville a été un révélateur
supplémentaires donc c'est bien évident
et on voit bien que la difficulté de
recruter dans des ehpad l'hôpital des
aides soignantes ou de mal sonel qui est
quand même assez criante le directeur
n'est pas dit il peut pas faire
autrement sauf il a pas le personnel
donc le service est payé par mais n'est
pas rendu et on maltraite en fin de
compte de cette façon là des gens qui
sont soit disant dans un ehpad
médicalisé qui ne l'est pas
romain gagnent au sol et sur la
situation dans les écoles j'entends ce
qui peut être dit par contre je serais
quand même moins catégorique et moi je
les pas de bashing aujourd'hui passe
quelque chose sur lequel j'essaye de
mettre en pot oui elle est épanouie des
situations catastrophiques on va on
parle d pas de 50 % des résidents sont
morts pendant une année de provident
donc mis sur des situations qui
interpelle après le phénomène de fonte
des ehpad les diffuser pad a commencé
bien avant le convient d'être accenture
celui de mâcon sable proville et il est
de deux natures
la première c'est la surmédicalisation
des résidents en ehpad
aujourd'hui le gmp moyens au pathé ni ne
fait qu'augmenter en ehpad et on se
retrouvait des populations en ehpad qui
sont extrêmement dépendante
sachant que tous les états n'étaient pas
faits pour à l'origine
pouvoir accepter des personnes aussi
dépendante rothen sera donc comme sans
rappeler le deuxième phénomène de fond
qui touche les ehpad de touche à
l'attractivité des métiers
il est devenu depuis 18 mois donc avant
même le coc vide de plus en plus
difficile de recruter des aides
soignants en ehpad donc l'arrivée du coc
vie des gens qui étaient totalement de
la commune qui fait totalement
imprévisible n'a fait que renforcer les
difficultés d'un secteur qui est d'un
secteur qui étaient déjà confrontés à
des structures elles de fond et qui ne
sont pas dus qu'aux fêtes et des acteurs
privés qui reversent des dividendes on
peut s'interroger sur niveau les acteurs
publics avaient des difficultés de fonds
avant et après je tiens à rappeler comme
que les directeurs d'ehpad quels qu'ils
soient sont vos une situation très
particulière où sont responsables
pénalement de tout ce qui se passe dans
leur établissement
aujourd'hui ils sont attaqués par les
favoris par les résidents par les
pouvoirs publics
mais six mélodies sont pénalement
responsables et peuvent avoir on va dire
des consignes contradictoires de leur
ministère de tutelle de leurs organismes
qui font que dans une situation
impossible dans quelques mois on
s'interrogera vraiment sur le bord
notent des directeurs d'ehpad voire même
sur la capacité à recruter des
directeurs d'ehpad coup quand on compare
leur salaire de recrutement leurs
responsabilités le fait qu'ils
travaillent 24 heures sur 24 depuis
promis de directeur des fans sont
épuisés je pense qu'on va avoir un vrai
problème de recrutement en ehpad et qui
ne va pas mais que contribuer encore au
mal-être danser et pas de là donc j'ai
dit oui posons nous les bonnes questions
sur les ehpad
mais je parle en attention n'allez pas
de bashing sachant de l'ehpad bashing
répond aussi aux besoins pour héberger
une partie des retraités qui n'ont pas
d'internât tibet qui n'en n'ont pas
aujourd'hui il faut des ehpad parce
qu'ils répondent quand même à une
problème est spécifique sur laquelle il
n'y a pas d'alternative sait combien le
prix moyen de
dans les pattes c'est quand même assez
élevé c'est dans l'est au moins deux
mille 2000 euros ou 3000 ce genre de
3600 c'est pas rien c'est pas rien
dominique battre contre le temps il y
avait très fortes inégalités
territoriales est aujourd'hui temps tous
les enjeux de la transition
démographique ce sont sont assez
intéressants parce que le discriminant
et très rarement l'âge dans les anges de
la transition démographique mais plutôt
des discriminant qui sont ou sociaux ou
territoriale et c'est valable
aujourd'hui
on a vécu le confinement silva c'est
valable à lui produit les crocs nice est
valable sur tout un tas de solutions
donc voilà il ya une transition
démocratique de fond qui font que les
gens vieillissent mais si on doit
travailler sur les crimes une enceinte
elle y sont discriminants territoriaux
ou sociaux et ça c'est généralement
oublié dans les discours qu'on a sur la
politique du vieillissement
dominique boulbès d'or dans votre livre
le vieillissement et ses enjeux pour les
nuls vous parlais justement de ne les
pas de demain qu'est-ce qu'elle sol et
les mesures qu'il faudrait prendre pour
que justement ce que le critique et donc
notamment robert cadalbert ne ne se
produise pas que les fonds les personnes
qui sont en ehpad puisse puisse vieillir
je dirais avec avec bonheur ou dans des
temps heureux
alors d'abord je voulais rebondir sur ce
que disait monsieur gallo romains gano
il a raison si on regarde le nombre
d'incidents qu'on a vu en ait pas de
rapporter au nom de résidence c'est
ridicule c'est à dire qu'il ya ya un
professionnalisme et des acteurs du
secteur et ça c'est pas du politiquement
correct parce que moi mon boulot c'est
de faire en sorte que les gens n'aillent
pas on n'est pas chez le concurrent des
ehpad mes concurrents et pat je peux
absolument garanti avant tout à fait
raison de le souligner qu'il ya un
travail extrêmement difficile et une
espèce de loisirs de poids nature du
chef qui est fait en permanence et ça
c'est pas une question du public ou
privé ou d'actionnaires
je ne sais quoi c'est vraiment un
travail qui est presque qui est parce qu
impossible avec une pénurie
une pénurie de personnel et donc il ya
vraiment deux pistes qui sont en train
de se dessiner
on va dire pour faire simple
décloisonner numérisés décloisonner ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que jusqu'à
présent on avait une espèce de da
proches binaire de la soluce du lac
estion pardon en disant il ya soit je
reste 2006 soit je vais en ait pas de
plus en plus aisés pas se spécialise
dans les pathologies démentiel ah vous
le savez il ya souvent doit être le sien
il ya des gens encore validé puis le
premier étage pour quoi que ça se
mélange où on a ce soir ça où on allait
les personnages n'est pas illogique
et puis de plus en plus on voit
apparaître j'avais fait une émission sur
sur une radio nationale sur le sujet on
va paraître une espèce de continuum de
solution entre donc le domicile et puis
les pattes vous avez des résidences
services pas les gens louent son
propriétaire de petits appartements avec
des services qui peuvent utiliser ou pas
et dans des degrés qui leur parti en
fonction de leur niveau d'autonomie
il ya ce qu'on appelle des béguinages
par exemple sur le modèle des béguines
du du xiiie siècle
enfin vous avez des 18 et de vie de 15 à
20 personnes de gens qui se rassemblent
pour vivre ensemble avec un tennis pas
d'auberges de jeunesse
pour des seniors et donc les pas
d'aujourd'hui leur défi c'est quoi leur
déficit de décloisonner de sortir de du
tout et bad et de s'articuler beaucoup
plus y'a que des missiles en composants
par exemple de transformer en espèces de
plateformes gérontologique japonais
j'habitais vingtaine d'avis dans les
évident mais je connais pas les maisons
de définition d'un père ça je venais pas
les maisons de retraite
là-bas mais vous avez dépassé en
gérontologie qui consiste à ce que
beaucoup de personnes au lieu d'avoir le
choix entre je reste à la maison où je
bascule complètement un départ pas ce
soit en accueil de jour soit simplement
quelques heures par semaine poursuit des
femmes kuniko pour voilà vous avez des
pas de l'inversement qui offre des soins
de ssd deux échassières de services de
soins 2002 et de rééducation et donc une
espèce de porosité qui se met en place
entre l'ehpad et la collectivité
environnement et dépasse transforme une
espèce de plate forme d'anthologie qui
prestent des services bien sûr dans ses
murs mais aussi du service hors de ses
murs je ne sais pas bien dans les
yvelines mais mais c'est ce qu'on voit
apparaître un peu partout et le deuxième
axe c'est numérique parce que on oppose
souvent le numérique à l'humain mais
c'est pas vrai si on parle par exemple
de la robotique
moi j'ai vu des expériences faites au
japon / robotique vous avez des
personnes âgées atteintes de pathologies
démentiel qui retrouve une espèce une
espèce de vie comme ça parce que il ya
un petit robot qui est là qui peut être
là tout le temps alors qu'une personne
humaine ça se paie mieux oui mais il ne
peut pas être là tout le temps et vous
avez après dans le quotidien de la
gestion aux ehpad et des solutions
numériques de commande à distance de
signaux de surveillants d'intelligence
artificielle qui détecte des anomalies
de comportement i
l'ailier chez passif typiquement vous
avez une start up
il savait que j'appelle du bic weeds et
amis des puces rfid dans les vêtements
de façon à ce que les personnes âgées ne
perdent pas leur linge donc il ya plein
de solutions numériques et ça c'est
vraiment un des défis auxquels france
actuellement les maisons de retraite
plein de solutions numériques qui permet
de soulager les personnels soignants et
les personnels administratifs
il faut proposer des choses c'est pas
c'est pas le numérique verse soudain une
espèce de d'aproz bizarre comme ça non
le numérique peut soulager lé vin parce
qu'il permet justement soyons de se
concentrer plus sur la relation que la
passion est moins des tâches de
surveillance
donc il ya vraiment une cette condition
là l'ouverture sur l'extérieur et
numériques dans les épaules
la nouvelle est justement le numérique
important en amérique très important le
département a d'ailleurs misé là dessus
a créé ce qu'on a appelé un hub
économies pour accompagner des start up
qui qui sont prometteuses dans ce
domaine là pour les accompagner pendant
un an leur donner le lait champ
d'expérimentation nécessaire l'ordonné
l'ingénérie nécessaire et puis faire
émerger des solutions innovantes pour le
pour les ehpad mais aussi pour le
maintien à domicile parce que ça sera
aussi un élément majeur de du maintien à
domicile
bouchard l'avancé parce que finalement
c'est là c'est là à la fusion au
traitement les startups les jeunes les
personnes âgées et il ya il ya une
solidarité ou fond derrière derrière
tous derrière tout ça aussi un oui c'est
ça c'est comme quand monsieur bull
baptisée c c'est garder ce lien toujours
et puis faire des balades et des
structures dedans-dehors passé très
importante les transporteurs de
décloisonner c'est vrai que les ehpad et
et des choses permet
et c'est vrai qu'il faut les ouvrir aux
mayrand tél la plateforme générique ap
je parlais du sial d'affirmer qu'ils
vont à domicile des accueils de jour on
voit monter maintenant un centre de
répit qui est un peu plus loin que que
l'accueil de jour
on a le centre de show room pour tout le
matériel qui est là et puis physiquement
avec les startups hong hao d'avis qui
s'occupe de ça sur sur le plateforme du
maire en tête on a une petite start up
qui a vu un grand c blue léna blou li na
a été créée à saint quentin en yvelines
et est encore à elle encore aujourd'hui
donc on a effectivement en plein champ
soit complètement phase moi c'était bien
on est en phase sur les solutions c'est
il n'y a pas une solution
c'est tout le sens d'une chaîne de deux
solutions et c'est dans cette chaîne
qu'on essaye là de mettre sur cette
plateforme
tout ce qui manque en particulier
peut-être pour la le plus important la
formation quand je dis on a mis une
école d'ergothérapeutes au maire en tête
il ya les kinés et il ya plein de deux
formation des aides-soignants parce que
le défi de demain
c'est d'abord formé alors vous me direz
fort mais ça ne suffit pas aux filles il
faut les payer parce que souvent il faut
que ça soit attractif
les gens qui vont rentrer désirent
perdre aux thérapeutes qui l'est où les
iraniens s'ils absolument à paris donc
il faut que ça soit reconnu et ne peut
pas tirer la ficelle d'un côté c'est une
chaîne et la chaîne de la formation de
tous ces professions de santé qui sont
aux prêts et qu'ils seront un lien
évident surtout ce qui est évidement le
maintien à domicile est fondamentale
vous vouliez
je pense que l'eepad demain doit être
l'exception
il faut vraiment misé sur le maintien
domicile faut vraiment faire en sorte
que les gens virus le vieux le mieux
possible le plus longtemps possible à
domicile pour prévenir la perte
d'autonomie les les pac doit devenir
l'exception et en maintenant ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure quand même le lien
social parce qu'il a eues on a eu les on
a eu des cas notamment quand et la
canicule nous a perçu le nombre de gens
qui mouraient seuls chez eux c'était été
c'était absolument faux dominic gould
bassinoise plus beaucoup de temps mais
je voulais en une minute est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire ce qu'est la silver
economy et quel est le marché au fond
d'eux du vieillissement
alors une minute c'est une gageure mais
j'en ai lui tendre un talent et je
regardais de deux trois minutes pour
qu'on parle aussi du transhumanisme
parce que tu as partant est ce qu'on va
vivre parce que l'enfant qui va 1500
temps est déjà né ferait silva économie
donc c'est globalement la façon des
entreprises s'adaptent fait que leur
client vieillissent
voilà donc l'acier des économies si je
le fais très très court vous avez 3 hier
vous avez le sac de l'autonomie des gens
qu'il fallait vraiment sur la dépendance
des gens spécialisés maisons de retraite
ou autre sur la dépendance
vous avez des spécialistes des gens qui
travailleront pour les seniors dames a
par exemple un senior la presse seniors
notre temps qu'une vie des choses comme
ça des gens viendraient et sujet des
biens des services spécialisés pour les
seniors et puis vous avez surtout et ça
se diffuse de plus en plus des grandes
entreprises qui prennent conscience que
la population vit et qui doivent
s'adapter
des groupes comme le grand comme saint
gobain comme d'autres ont créé des
cellules seniors en disant bas à jour il
va falloir qu'on s'adapte
il faut qu'on commence et donc essayer
d'avoir une vision longue sur le sujet
j'ai par exemple le groupe legrand qui
commence à fabriquer des prises
électriques ça paraît tout bête mais à
80 centimètres du sol ou de les mettre à
sac est difficile surtout actuellement
et ça paie
ça change tout dans un quotidien et donc
ces sachets des économies c'est vraiment
le la diffusion du vieillissement de la
population dans les dents le dans le
cadrage intellectuelle dans le cadre
stratégique des décideurs en entreprise
roumégas nous vous êtes un praticien au
fond de la salle vers iqaluit
ah oui courir avant même que la tribu
leur économie existe car le terme et un
exit 2015
mais de fait on traite déjà là dedans
avant je lui avais d'ailleurs dans la
structure économie des travaux pour être
mené par le fbi autonomie parce que pas
avoir vu le dossier récemment ont
collaboré avec eux dans le cadre au sein
de l'agglo âgées autonomie et ce qui est
fait dans les yvelines et pour moi il ya
ces structures en termes de filières
accompagnement start up et déploiement
de terrain d'expérimentation aujourd'hui
ce qui est intéressant dans la silver
economy com dominique abisse etc
cet écart d'activité globale qui
s'identifie aujourd'hui pas plus par ses
clients que par son métier et où on voit
aujourd'hui de 300 acteurs qui se
réunissent régulièrement mais qui dans
lesquels aussi des entreprises des
partenaires les collectivités publiques
des groupes de protection sociale des
mutuelles lui tous ayant à coeur les
enjeux du vieillissement
l'enjeu de demain pour voir ce trader
fait ressortir la silver economy des
murs et aujourd'hui n'ont ni trahi dans
le cadre des marques part il faut que
des acteurs aujourd'hui qui n'est pas
encore est conscient de ce
vieillissement de cette transition
démocratique la suite dedans ont occupé
un premier niveau de conscience dont on
en a cité saint gobain legrand mais qui
sont un petit peu près sûr ça fait des
années qu'on travaille dessus mais
demain pour moi les acteurs devront le
prendre en compte sont les acteurs de
l'automobile
on va très simple aujourd'hui un client
de me paraît plus inclure votre nation
doit c'est un contrat de plus en france
donc l'ensemble des filières
industrielles françaises on voit touchée
par la transition démographique et je
pense même que dans une au prix de
relance économique et de relance
solidaire il faudra qu'une prise en
compte de ces enjeux du vieillissement
aujourd'hui un consommateur sur deux
aura soit retraité autre étape bientôt
en france au panneau mire un mot pour
terminer sur le transhumanisme le
transhumanisme c'est l'homme augmenté
cetc des recherches qui sont réels
notamment aux états unis avec désirs
tout où les dollé tous les tous les
maîtres du gaf à rechercher dépense
beaucoup d'argent là-dessus on dit déjà
que l'homme l'homme qui va vivre trois
cents ans et déjà donné
dominique boulbès seo peut y croire
alors oui on peut y croire parce que
quand on parle avec des spécialistes
avec dès que j'ai interviewés pour mon
bouquin ou moins livre pardon avec des
professeurs de génératrices disent tous
la même chose c'est que le il n'y a pas
de face et de fatalité au vieillissement
c'est carrément donné dans la mécanique
biologique il ya un accident qui se
produit qui fait que le cocon à se
dégrader
il n'y a pas de facilité aujourd'hui la
firme qui avait style le plus d'argent
dans le transhumanistes mais la
recherche d'une vie à cent cinquante ans
de 150 à 500 ans voire éternelle eh bien
figurez vous que c'est google donc dire
qu'ils sont aussi mais enfin ils sont
capables de faire des choses
ils ont créé un laboratoire de recherche
fait fallou fall tall s'appelle calicots
et il étudie notamment un râteau qui vit
sous la terre et si on prend son
espérance de vie quand la plaque sur la
prostitution de la vie humaine ça nous
fait vivre jusqu'à 400 ans donc il ya
pas mal de chercheurs est vraiment des
gens des gens très sérieux je me
trouvais offert cannes par exemple
qu'ils disent oui l'homme tiendra deux
cent cinquante ans il n'est pas possible
qu'il soit n'est pas ce que les jeunes
et aujourd'hui vont vivre une centaine
d'années et donc il est extrêmement
probable que dans les 30 à 40 ans qui
arrive on arrive à trouver le secret de
la vie à 200 250 300 ans
c'est pas c'est pas impossible du tout
merci à la balle juste alors pour hbo
pour terminer c'est pas pour nous ça ça
vient un peu tard mais c'est un pur est
ce que pour vos petits enfants par
exemple vous souhaiter qu'ils puissent
vivre 360 je pense
la galerie non mais rapidement la durée
et par l'élément essentiel pour moi
c'est la qualité l'égalité si c'est 300
ans dans un tunnel comme une taupe à
faire
humanisme envers les trois saisons comme
on est à peu près à 50 ans donc c'est
pareil c'est pas mal barry lane ouvert
déjà prononcé sur mars peut-être cet
encours on n'a pas abordé le problème de
la retraite et de l'allongement de l'âge
de travail romain gayot ça vous y croyez
vous aussi moi j'écris mes parents je me
focaliserai pas là dessus pour deux
questions pour deux raisons la première
car pour cela il ya des enjeux de la
transition démographique sera réglé tout
de suite et qui est qu'en focalisant la
question sur le transhumanisme on met la
technologie avant le service
donc moi je j'entends tout ce qui s'y
dit j'ai d'ailleurs j'y crois mais je
dis pour les enjeux d'aujourd'hui
gardons en tête que le bien vivre avant
tout une économie de services et qu'il
faut travailler aujourd'hui surtout sur
basque et services de proximité pour
tous accessible au plus grand nombre
ça c'est le premier élément est sûre le
deuxième sur l'allongement de l'abissa
poser des questions fondamentales qui
sont déjà celles d'aujourd'hui est pas
l'allongement de la retraite aujourd'hui
c'est l'allongement des différents temps
de la vie si on regarde aujourd'hui les
jeunes générations
elles passent plus de temps chez leurs
parents plus de temps à étudier vont
passer plus de temps à travailler et
passeront plus de temps à la retraite
est une question vraiment de qualité de
la vie sur l'ensemble de l'allongement
des différents temps de la vie qui va se
poser ok merci merci infiniment à tous
anne boucharlat je rappelle votre
émission c'est tous les jeudis je crois
sur jeudi de 18 heures à 19 heures
dominique boulbès le vieillissement et
ses enjeux pour les nuls c'est dans
cette célèbre collection et essai alors
marie hélène aubert voulez vous faire
dédicacer votre livre malheureusement
vous êtes en vision donc on peut pas
faire comme si
des voiliers merci infiniment
[Musique]